hey
oh uh welcome to fat man beyond i'm
kevin smith
my name is mark bernard hey
thank you sorry for the latest
uh but whatever it's all cleared up now
and we we all
got the wrong coordinates for the drop
and so we all had to
kind of scramble a bit um we yeah
it was uh hey you know what you don't
need to see backstage you don't want to
see how
sausage is [ __ ] made sometimes even
if it's vegan sausage
because especially if it's vegan yeah
you
where's the pork ladies and gentlemen
that's what you say when you tune into
fat man beyond and every week we pork
you
real hard me and mark bernardin right
here man
intelligent you're the anal vice we are
the anal blocks
right before we went good to let go
right before we went
we were talking about you know of course
we'll get to later in the show we lost
the great christopher plummer this week
um christopher plummer you know for
people of a certain age
uh i'm sure for today's kids
he's mr knives out which is fine
um and for many people he was mr kevin
spacey in a number of movies
fine but to me and mark who were born
like in the 70s of course
he'll always be captain von trot from
the
sound of music i suspect quite like
myself mark might have been forced to
watch a time or two through childhood
more than once it was a huge event
it's like every christmas on abc like
hey it's sound of music time
okay i mean like yeah it's it's just
there were a couple things you were
forced to watch the wizard of oz because
they played it like once a year
[ __ ] that gone with the win which i
escaped watching
every year of my life man good for you
like oh my god that seemed like a big
commitment and [ __ ]
but uh yeah sometimes they just put [ __ ]
on and we're like this is a [ __ ]
event and stuff like that ten
commandments was the other one that was
always in rotation like you gotta see
you gotta learn this story great a story
ever told like
okay if you went to catholic school like
me are you kidding me they were shoving
moses up your [ __ ] a-hole man so
naturally
[ __ ] ten commandments wasn't just
like oh it's a sunday night let's kick
back and watch a movie
you're doing homework [ __ ]
learn why moses
[ __ ] it up for himself because the
scary thing about the moses story right
is that he's the [ __ ] chosen one
and he leads everybody you know out
israelites out of
[ __ ] persecution and and [ __ ] more
or less
you know conquers uh the egyptians right
and then he don't even get to go into
the promised land he has to sit on a
hill
for the rest of his life looking isn't
that [ __ ] cucking it out
that's the horror story of [ __ ] moses
right there man
that's how they teach you to be good
when you're a kid like you don't want to
be [ __ ] full mowing it up
like moses missing out on our
old foe moses
[Laughter]
in any event so before we went uh we
were talking about
uh christopher plummer of course was in
uh
uh uh sound of music and song
uh if you've ever seen hollywood babylon
uh ralph
sings it uh is that captain von trapp is
very well known for
is the song edelweiss
edelweiss which i believe refers to a
plant in germany some
chicken flower national flower of
germany or something like that
years ago you know then in
you know the sound of music it's
partially about how the national flower
of germany became hatred
and nazism like that's also part of the
movie and [ __ ] but
before [ __ ] went bad he's austrian right
he ain't even german right yes he's
austrian
so he's saying i guess that's the
national flower of austria and stuff and
nothing bad could ever come from austria
so he's singing this song edelweiss in
the movie
and mark said i have for my entire life
thought and you cannot correct me that
the name of that
song is anal vice a-n-a-l-v-i-c
like a department of the police that
just deals in anal crimes
that's what mark was thinking mark said
and i said an anal vice i said would
that hold you open or close
i went to a different vice and then mark
was like no man i meant like anal vice
like you know like miami voice you know
it's like oh like anal vice and [ __ ]
and the thought was this
i mean it's probably just funny to us
but [ __ ] it was enjoyable
then the thought was anal vice
was like the 80s conception of the
hardest a cop
show could ever be like [ __ ] them
sitting around going like
what's the worst crime that could be
perpetrated
in the 80s and they're like anal vice
but put them hard cops are on anal vice
no pun intended
so we were talking about how the [ __ ]
would you deal with
you know how how do you reboot anal vice
in 2021 where like anal is on the menu
right after kissing it's no longer
the big taboo what would it be called
and then all of a sudden jc was like can
we start the show
so like this is adorable boys let's
start a show
thank you for sitting through all that
uh let me tell you something
kids i don't care if it's edelweiss
or anal vice either way you always want
to smell your prettiest
you know what i'm saying and this week's
sponsor
ladies and gentlemen uh they they make
you smell so pretty
even if you were trapped in an anal vice
you wouldn't even know it man
uh because they could take that scent
away
wow did we lose kev in the middle of a
native deo ad
i think we did but hey let's just
[ __ ] talk about native deo
native deodorant is formulated without
aluminum parabens or talc it's also
vegan
because you know one of us here really
cares about stuff that's vegan
um it's it's so you can you can eat it
if you're vegan but it's never tested on
animals it's made with ingredients
you've heard of like coconut oil
and shea butter and you wear deodorant
every day shouldn't be able to
understand all the ingredients that are
in it
you know it's wait did we lose everybody
are we back now
can i i think do we have a kev we're
having a kev hold on i'm gonna talk
about amazing sense
i hear him is he back
baby i'm back i swear ah
i swear he's back i'm here
do you want to talk about the amazing
sense that native deodorant offers can
you see
me i can see you i can hear you
i i was i was talking about it
when suddenly i was offline once again i
have the worst [ __ ] internet
connection
in the world um and people keep trying
to tell me like you should do this you
should do that
there's nothing to be done shy of
hanging a satellite over the [ __ ]
house
um somebody maybe jc could explain it
but whatever
regardless regardless it comes and goes
but my point was and i was [ __ ]
screaming into the [ __ ] screen uh
native d.o
ladies and gentlemen nativedeo.com
go to nativedeo.com batman use the promo
code
fatman at checkout and you're gonna get
20
off your first order man that's native
d-e-o what do you
you want a [ __ ] stink no you don't
you go to nativedeo.com
fat man or use the promo code fat man
at checkout and you're gonna get 20 off
your first order and you're like what am
i getting
you're getting that native deodorant
mass formulated without
aluminum or as they say in england
aluminium
it's got no paraben i don't know what
those are
got probably from the dark side
dimension they're in the snyder cut
lots of parabens and [ __ ] like that um
even though both mark and i as babies
were [ __ ]
bathed in talc and we turned out just
fine
talc is the secret of all good writers
people are against talc nowadays and
[ __ ]
native says [ __ ] the talc we can do it
without the talc and they did they're
goddamn magicians the best part of this
[ __ ]
for a guy like me who cares ethical and
awesome
it's [ __ ] vegan mark this [ __ ] is
plant-based
if i have to if society collapses not
only am i [ __ ] freshening up
i'm eating that [ __ ] man i ain't got to
worry as i eat it i'm not crying like oh
[ __ ] a baby cow had to
no i could just eat that [ __ ] and it
it's
it smells so good you want to eat it
sometimes i literally told my wife
tonight
she was like you got a box of [ __ ] and
it was from a different company all
together she's like is this your
commercial for the week or something i
said no this is for next week i believe
in stuff
uh i said tonight we're doing native
deodorant she goes oh my god did they
send stuff
and i was like you love it huh she's
like i'm a [ __ ] for native i said i'm
gonna steal that line
and sell it to the good folks native so
there's your new catch phrase man
just cut to a dude or a lady i'm poor
for native you know
very suggestive sex sells you know what
i'm talking about
um you know you know what else sells
ingredients
that you know are [ __ ] wholesome man
uh
native and deodorant is made with
ingredients you've heard of
like coconut oil and shea butter this
ain't like some [ __ ] [ __ ] from space
where you're like what's venom in this
it's [ __ ] natural man you wear
deodorant every day shouldn't you be
able to understand the ingredients list
[ __ ] sounds reasonable no it does
i'm looking forward to the mad max
future where instead of dinty moore dog
food
mad max is just chowing down on native
deodorant bars
because you could you griddle that [ __ ]
up it's all good man you take off
the head plate that's protecting your
open skull
your [ __ ] exposed brain you put that
on top of a fire
like a rock style and [ __ ] and then you
put your native dio
in there and [ __ ] just cook it for a
good five each side
that's good eating especially only in
the post-apocalyptic future kids
do not do this now you don't have to eat
no
but if you had to but if you had to
they got scents and flavors like coconut
and vanilla they're most popular
lavender and rose not so bad cucumber
and mint
huh citrus and herbal husk musk
making me hungry stop it you're making
me hungry and i don't eat past eight
o'clock you son of a [ __ ]
god damn it these are tasty players no
wonder my wife wants to
get a free box of the native i says to
her i says you got enough money to get
your own box i says and she said i [ __ ]
you i will and she went off to amazon
she ordered her own [ __ ] native man
can you believe it i said if you went to
nativedeo.com fat man you could have
gotten 20
off and she goes [ __ ] your commercial
ass
i said these commercials pay your bills
and she's like not my bills
i didn't actually go on the internet and
tell people how much you love [ __ ]
wanda vision
i said you know what you used to like
that about me when we first met
20 minutes that's how good native
deodorant is ladies and gentlemen
i like that that now we're just
rebooting all in the family but it's
about [ __ ] deodorant
we're trying to we're trying to do this
classy product placement you know how
every once in a while like snl
does like a product placement ad and
they build a sketch around it [ __ ] like
that
seth meyers recently did one with a beer
and i was like holy [ __ ]
so i figure if we work it in all smooth
as part of our bit
you know as long as the customer's not
like we don't want you to use the
post-apocalyptic future to sell our
deodorant and kill people
it really you shouldn't eat it and we're
like i know but if we were in a
post-apocalyptic future
oh we don't sell our product on [ __ ]
theoreticals
we are nativedio.com
n-a-t-i-v-e d e o
dot com [ __ ] respect don't
sell us mad max style sell us for what
we do
and what they do is they make it not
smell like you live in a
post-apocalyptic world
that's a better that's a better tagline
than i'm a horror for native
i guess that's the law we just iterated
a little bit we got there
we got there so listen free shipping on
every order in the u.s and
native offers 30-day free returns and
exchanges in the us so there's no risk
to try
if it's not your jam if you don't love
the way you smell you just send it back
so go get your money back but you know
what if you go to native.com
nativedeo.com fatman give it a shot
you're not going to want to return it
anyway no way man you're going to love
the way you don't stink anymore
nativedeo.com nativedeo.com
we thank them for being proud sponsors
of fat man beyond ladies and gentlemen
thank you to the good folks at native
nativedeo.com batman all right man
hey how you been sir what you've been
doing this week uh this week was a busy
week
because uh this week it uh at least
i can for the first time in a long time
say what i'm working on
which is nice to be able to do um
because i i feel for people when i was
like can you tell us what you're doing
it's like i can't i'm under ndas from 19
different people and they'll come and
take my children if i talk too much
but this week the news broke that i'm
writing a one-shot for marvel
as part of their heroes reborn um event
um which posits what if the avengers
never existed
what is this uh sort of who were the
heroes who filled the void
and what happens to some of the heroes
that we already know and love and so i'm
writing peter parker
the amazing shutterbug which is what if
peter parker was never bitten by a
spider
what's that dude's life like and uh and
it's been fun it's coming out in may
and and yeah i don't i don't write that
much
uh comic book material anymore and i
definitely don't do a lot of
sort of uh like big two work so it was
kind of fun to to be able to just like
yeah [ __ ] peter parker
anyway peter parker let's let's see what
peter parker's life would be like what
would he be up to
if swinging through the through the
skies and uh and snaring villains and
webs was not on the menu
uh that is dope who's your artist um
it is a guy named um rafael de torre
who i've never met um but i've seen a
lot of his work and so it's pretty dope
um it's a very fast schedule so this
week has been
um but uh uh it's been deadline heavy
so most of it is how many pages 20 pages
30 pages
it's a big fat book jeez man
that [ __ ] pretty pages this is a
that's a nut biter man
um it's it's for those that uh who have
never
tried or don't look you know into very
deeply into this sort of thing
writing a comic book script is far more
involved than writing almost any other
script
there is you can get away with writing a
tv script with very little
descriptive shorthand because as
the term indicates shorthand uh most
people
all understand the tropes and and
uh and visualizations of television and
whatnot you know
so when it comes to a comic book
as is often the case the writer and the
artist
who is going to be bringing those words
and that story to life and the pictures
are usually two completely different
people
and if the writer is the artist
then they could write their comic book
scripts the way i write my movie script
which is like well i'm going to be there
on set
so i know all the details [ __ ] i'm just
going to write as little as possible
like
dante comes in and sees randall i'm not
going to be like
the room is square you know the
atmosphere
dante 50 turns and feel how old does he
look or anything like that like
that's entertaining a reader and stuff
so i tend to leave that stuff out i'd
rather save the page count
for dialogue and stuff in comic book
scripts
you have to literally as a writer
describe
every single thing that you want to see
in the panel
otherwise it may not be there you can't
expect that the artist
is going to read your [ __ ] mind when
you write a script and unless it's
very detailed you know you see an image
and you're like but wait where's the
control panel
a writer will be like i don't see a
single thing in this
about a control panel being needed like
you have to describe
everything and by virtue of that like a
30 page comic script you know most
people like what is that 30 pages
how long was your script um it is
probably like i'm not done with it yet
um but it is probably going to
average i imagine it'll be about 50
pages long
maybe between 45 and 50 pages and so
it's a one shot
yeah you know and like to your point the
thing of it is
is that not only you're doing the
writing that you would do in a tv script
you know which is dialogue not only are
you doing the pros that you would do in
a novel because you've got to describe
all this stuff
but you're all so if you're writing full
script as opposed to marvel style
quote-unquote you're also choosing how
many panels are on a page and how many
balloons are each panel and
you're doing math in a way that you
don't really have to do
in any other form of writing which is i
got 30 pages how many panels on each
page
how many balloons in each panel how many
words in each balloon
and all of that's got to feel a certain
way and then you're like all right what
do i want on the page turn what's my
suspense here if you
if you open a book you're like my left
page is the first thing i see and then
the bottom of the right page
is just before the page turns you know
that gets to be suspense
or a massive plot twist or an emotional
beat so what's gonna be there and then
what do you see when you flip it over oh
that's [ __ ] badass it's a reveal
do you want spreads and splashes like
it's all of this thinking that you don't
have to do in any other form of writing
and it's really [ __ ] hard um and
by the way like in terms of uh
the financial recompense which is not
why
you do these things but let's say it was
um you don't make a lot of money
you know all that work you do the
aggregate of
what you get paid versus how much work
you put into it
the ratio is completely ratioed
to borrow from the kids yeah i mean you
have to be doing
volume in order to actually make a
living writing comics
and the more you have to do odds are
the worse it's going to be simply
because it becomes a factory becomes a
an assembly line and there are some
incredibly gifted people who can do it
and i have no idea how they do you know
when you when you hear
people you know like oh you know he's
got four monthly books five monthly
books like how the [ __ ] do you do this
you know what book what i say is first
thing i would say is hire the any of
those [ __ ] as a tv person because if
you can handle four comic book
titles a month or a week you can [ __ ]
handle
episodic television oh for sure turn out
to be great training for it
and also you writing a marvel book now
ever
is a great thing fun but like you doing
it now
like marvel comics are now under the
stewardship
of marvel kevin feige oversees the
comics now
um so you know and kevin foggy as we've
seen
is very happy to borrow
bits and pieces from storylines
all throughout the comics um
you know and put them together into what
we know and love about the marvel
cinematic universe so
getting a writing gig there is not just
fun
and man i'm writing [ __ ] comic books
at marvel
and um oh my god i'm working on the
heroes reborn thing
it's also back to her like you never
know who's gonna read this
yeah back in the day when i wrote
daredevil i was never like i wonder if
anyone's going to
[ __ ] turn this into
i think we lost you oh we lost kev again
usually when he goes out he goes out um
picture first
but we can still we'll hear him
oh and that is the most unflattering
freeze frame
i hear him is he back maybe
i'm back ah hey
how's back welcome
my computer keeps telling me my internet
connection is unstable
yeah i get that a lot i try and sit it
down
let it relax a bit like you're a little
wound up kid
come on tiger
but yeah so it's so it's so frustrating
i
i i like i feel like like i'm moving
this [ __ ] around
like you'd move rabbit ears on a tv
you know as i don't know [ __ ] about the
internet you know i [ __ ] use it like
crazy
and have since 1994 but like i don't
know how [ __ ] actually works
so like you know some people like jack
in
man and i'm like all right but how like
the laptop i'm on doesn't even have
well ethernet jacks anymore and stuff i
don't know i'm [ __ ] so lost i'm such
a befuddled old man
and i was on a roll and also not looking
for a reaction you were frozen i was
like [ __ ]
i forget what i was even talking about
so what i'm talking about marvel
what happens is um
he's gonna say what happens at your
house is the
infrastructure the the amount of money
it costs to shut down hollywood
boulevard to run the fiber optic and the
cable lines
to the hollywood hills north of
hollywood boulevard
is so much money and so prohibitive
because scum and villain is right on the
other side of hollywood boulevard
so when i needed to get better internet
i had to put like you said a satellite
dish on the roof
to get better internet that is not
possible even for cost wise even for the
people in hollywood hills
i tried to get normal internet and they
said it would take
three years of permitting to get the
city to shut down hollywood boulevard to
run the line
under the street so that's why you and
everybody who's north of hollywood
boulevard is host
thank you jc everybody
i always get people going like come on
man you're [ __ ] rich once you get
better internet
[ __ ] rich and i'm like number one not
rich
i have to work a lot number two i
thought i had
the best internet i could possibly get
and it turns out i'm
right but the problem is the best
internet i could give
is not very good as jc just told us but
uh next week hopefully we'll be doing
this from scum and villainy and so
indeed this [ __ ] [ __ ] won't matter
but anyway before we lose everybody as
we move into the subject of like [ __ ]
you know net neutrality and [ __ ] like
that let's
know what we came here to talk about
before that
a quick plug yes everyone's been going
like hey man
[ __ ] when we gonna get some he-man
when we gonna get some masters of the
universe
um i'm just gonna say
monday morning you might want
quitters you might want to check your
instagrams
could be something worth some info there
again
don't want to get people excited not a
trailer or something like that but
there's something is it going to be the
announcement that mark hamill
wrote a whole episode by himself um
starring me
you see that somebody show screen rant
did a story
and they you know took something i was
talking about mark bernardin
my co-host and i was talking about how
mark's got his own show like
episode three is the show that mark
wrote and so
uh i said mark episode three is all
marked
and the screen rant writer took that to
mean that
skeletor gets his own episode and
because he thought i was talking about
mark hamill
not mark bernard but i'm like my
my biggest issue with that story was
like you think skeletor is getting
one episode like there's
there's two [ __ ] main characters in
this franchise is he man
and right after him and perhaps right
next to him and in many cases
probably above him is skeletors go to
her plays throughout this whole [ __ ]
thing man he don't get his own episode
it's his [ __ ] show so you know
that was a little strange but i was
talking about mark of course
so in the future i will say mark with a
k
or mark of the c
there you go seymour k mark
um okay but uh yes monday
if you're interested in motu there might
be something for you to
to watch
[Music]
wanda vision
boom episode five dropped correct
indeed uh for my money
best of the bunch uh i don't even have
to [ __ ] sell
my wife on this show anymore man she's
like is it on
and like now she's just
wavy hands hmm
see i'm a little loathe to dive in
right here and talk about hornet fell
oop he's back
he's back [ __ ] what did i miss god damn
it
and all we heard was uh i don't even
have to
beg my wife to watch because she just
wants to know when it's on
are you [ __ ] me yeah
i sh i said so much more after that
i hate this i know can't stand this it's
unfucking believable man
like and i'm
ugh you look despondent
like it don't have to be this way i mean
apparently it does because like jc said
they can't lay a [ __ ] wire
someplace but i feel despondent
like
i look like i know it's real like you
discover problems and [ __ ] like that i
know there's bigger issues
it's just i feel like we're on a delay
now too
here you are you can hear me i can hear
you
all right start talking about one
division i'm going to sign off and sign
back on go
okay all right so
listen here's the thing i i i really dug
this episode
i dug it quite a bit um and because it's
sort of beginning to pay off what we
saw in episode 4 and what i hoped would
happen which was a dual storyline right
like we would get
what was happening with wanda and viz
inside the
the simalacrum um
and then we would get what was happening
outside the walls of the hex with
with darcy and uh and monica and jimmy
um and so the the ways that those two
things began to inform each other and
play off with each other and
start revealing things about the the
nature and the reality of
of what wanda has erected or whether or
not she is also the victim of something
because there's lots of talk about
how she was never this powerful even
though yes she was one almost took down
um thanos you know but wanda herself
even says that she doesn't
have any recollection of creating any of
this that she is not the person who's
helping every one of these thousand
people who are stuck in west
um he's back um
in west view go to the dentist or walk
their dogs any of that stuff she's not
controlling everybody on a micro basis
um but you know she's she's both in
control and not in control
um which is you know heartbreaking and
vision all of the [ __ ] vision stuff
where he's beginning to realize that the
world is
is not what he thought it was that he
can't remember anything that happened
before
they got to west view um there's real
tragedy there real
anger there you know especially once you
realize that part of his living will was
that he would not be resurrected like
once he died
he was supposed to be dead and now he's
not because the woman who loved him
um didn't respect that and out of her
own
grief and anger and anguish
she brought him back from the dead um
all of this stuff is fantastic and i
love
i love the way we're beginning to sort
of fletch these emotional
and and sort of psychological realities
into this story um the the thing that i
found myself wanting
uh was just a a refocusing on
perspective
you know like my my my ideal version of
this show
would have been we open with
with uh monica rembo waking up from the
blip and then you have her go through
all of that stuff
and you basically episode four kind of
could have been episode one
and if the idea is she and jimmy wu are
together ex-filing this [ __ ] anomaly
that's in the middle of new jersey right
and so
she goes in and we then see the tv show
from her perspective and what's
happening in here and then she meets
wanda
and then wanda is weird and and
and unsettling and why is we why are we
in a sitcom
i think is the question that you want
somebody to be asking
that isn't just the audience that is
actually in the drama
and then if you do it that way then you
you have a character that you're
following who wants something you
set up her relationship to wanda and
understand
what she's all about because someone's
putting grief on the stage very early on
and you can still have all of the weird
mettiness and you can still have all of
the decade by decade
progression and you can still have all
those questions while somebody's asking
them
actively from within the story and then
she gets booted out and then the story
sort of continues on that pace but
just a slight reframing of the narrative
for me
would have made this a a less somewhat
frustrating experience
um which is you know part of the reason
why i like this episode the most
um because it's giving you all of that
stuff you're getting the pain
from one's perspective you're getting
the pain from visions perspective
you're getting answers to who and why
and what
um and i don't need answers from the
beginning that's not what i'm saying i'm
happy
to be in the dark a little bit i'm happy
to be um
a conspiratorial viewer you know like
that's that's what mystery tv does it
takes you by the hand
and walks you into the story and then
leads you astray and gives you all kinds
of [ __ ] red herrings and and bad
clues and
dead ends that's part of the fun but i
just need a little bit of that hand
holding and a little bit of that active
sort of dismantling of what i'm looking
for and what i'm expecting to get
um but yes all of that is to say i think
this is the best episode of the show so
far
um because it's kind of doing it's doing
the work that i have been doing
for so much um of the time but that's
just me
kev how do you feel i feel angry mark
why can't i get a better internet
connection
like i feel like i know it's a first
world problem i should shut my mouth but
i'm
so i'm i'm confused and like
like vision i don't know i don't
understand what happened
and why it has to be this way and also
because
it had never been this bad before
unbelievable like i feel
like [ __ ] like people must out there
they're like what are you
running it on a pay phone you gotta put
a quarter in every [ __ ]
two minutes to work where you got
[ __ ] squirrels
running around on [ __ ] treadmills to
make your internet go
so embarrassing like we're doing a show
that like gets watched
by a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand people a week
between multiple platforms and i'm like
god i hope my dial up holds
[Music]
it's just a lesson for anybody out there
it's like oh man you make movies you
must be you live in hollywood you must
be on easy street
not at all no say i don't know if you're
familiar with a magazine called
us weekly there's a feature inside of it
called
stars they're just like us
and i don't know if i'm a star but just
like many people my internet is [ __ ]
it's bad real [ __ ] bad
like and i can't do nothing about it i
got people messaging me going like here
this could have
literally we had jc just come on and
talk about it so there's
yeah people in chat are like try the
starling from elon musk and try the 5g
so i went on while people are saying
that and i googled all of them i put
your address in
none of them are available at your
address like there is
you are just hosed we're in a dead zone
here
like honestly they want me to live a
[ __ ] life
where i'm like paying attention to my
family and like taking
care of like the house and [ __ ] like
when they built this neighborhood nobody
was thinking about the internet
[ __ ] sucks i'll tell you that right
now it's quiet
wi-fi is the great equalizer it really
is man [ __ ]
i you know here end of the [ __ ] i'm
sorry it's very frustrating
because i know i'm going to start my
review and it's going to be like
well you know and [ __ ] that's it for
20 minutes
um i loved this episode this is my
favorite one so far the show is exactly
what i hoped
it was going in um and they said the
magic word this week that i was
never able to express
succinctly i didn't use the term i
you know i was always like this show
feels like sad but
they used the term grief and that's
exactly what the whole thing is about
this is somebody processing their grief
writ [ __ ] large man and i think
that's what i found about it that
found so attractive about it before it
even started that's what i could smell
from the ads i'm like this is about
somebody [ __ ] dealing with incredible
loss and they're doing an excellent job
of telling that story and they're also
telling it still is a mystery
whereas like i you know i know more than
i did last week but i still don't know
what the [ __ ] going on
uh you know all bets are off as to
whether or not there's somebody behind
all this everyone on the internet keeps
wanting to make it mephisto
um you know but it could just be [ __ ]
wanda
doing it by herself like you know i
they're and i'm not saying that is it or
my thoughts
i'm just saying it's such a well-crafted
mystery that
every week i'm still not sure where
we're going how many episodes we got
left
i don't even know i think it might be
three more is it eight
this if this [ __ ] if a fly comes on
my screen
it's gonna slow my internet the amount
of pixels it's gonna take to recreate
that
i would never kill an instinct insect
but tonight i'd be close because i'm
like i can't lose a single
[ __ ] piece of internet man um
they're so close to the end at this
point like we're definitely over halfway
through because it ain't ten episodes
so about episode five um and it's
still a gripping mystery but now we know
that it's a gripping mystery
about one woman's grief and
the you know the remember a couple weeks
back
when she was like i have i had a brother
um you know he died i was like that was
one of my favorite
top five scenes in marvel
you know studios history
um one division in and of itself is
jumping into
top five status i find the sword story
equally compelling i i'd watch f
i'd watch 20 episodes of this i'm not
raising one to lower another and stuff
but like i
you know i've seen a few episodes of
shield but it never agents of shield but
it never connected with me
i'd watch a [ __ ] sword show six ways
to sunday and this is and it's not
because the agents of shield
show the wasn't good or the writers
weren't good
in this universe you can [ __ ]
reference
play with bring characters over
tie storylines in like you know jennifer
my wife she came in my office the next
day
after we watched it like thursday at 12
o'clock at night and she
you know friday at 12 in the morning
when it dropped when she woke up
she was just like i can't stop thinking
about that show
and she was like still like hitting
great points and i said
you know why i said it's like a soap
opera
i said they've just nailed the soap
opera thing you know for [ __ ] people
that like superheroes like
this is an ongoing story and just like a
soap opera
sometimes people who haven't followed
from the beginning or haven't seen
everything or like what's going on what
happened to this character who
who's cheating on who or whatever the
[ __ ] so she's playing a bit of ketchup
but she was like it is like a soap opera
the fact that they can like again
i don't want anyone writing on the
internet like [ __ ] smith shits on
agents of shield
what i enjoy more about this show is
that they can directly
relate or events reference events bring
in
characters in canon and stuff whereas
agents of shield
seem to always skirt around the
outskirts of the marvel universe if i'm
correct well i mean they
the first season of agents of shield you
know was very much
directly about the avengers the fallout
from the avengers
you know the attack on on manhattan but
like
you got nick fury once or twice like you
got
lady sif once like he would every now
and again
get something off the periphery of the
marvel universe
and then they just abandon it entirely
and like we're going to space and we're
going into the future and
time travel and and it almost became i
saw a story or two this week or last
week about how
agents of shield like was meant to
become
agents of sword once they went into
space
so like they were working toward it but
then they were told no
because the movie division was going to
be
[ __ ] with sword and boy are they
[ __ ] with in a good way
yeah um i i'd watch a long story short i
would [ __ ] watch
hours of just sword um it's
fascinating i loved you know one of my
new favorite [ __ ] scenes
uh top at least top 15
is wanda coming out and confronting
everybody
and she's got the accent back we have no
idea why
um she you know [ __ ] she's wearing
her outfit from infinity war and she's
wearing her boostie ache
in her full [ __ ] scarlet witch here
um
like that i love that whole [ __ ]
scene and then she pulled the magneto
move at the end
where all the guns turned on you know
just like her comic book dad which
based on what's going on with this show
could be her [ __ ] movie dad
as well as we saw the shock [ __ ]
ending
which wasn't all that shocking because
everyone kept telling us he's in the
show
um evan peters showed up as as the
quicksilver
as pietro and they make a [ __ ]
comment about it like she recast pietro
darcy says like almost like acting like
all of us the audience
and what a fantastic little twist where
you're like oh [ __ ]
now we don't know what's going on some
people on the internet are like that's
just mephisto
internet's got a hard-on for mephisto
and i i i other than that devil in the
details line
there's really no evidence to point to
that i don't feel like
they would rock us with a big bad out of
the blue you know what i'm saying like
one that nobody's ever heard of in the
marvel universe until now
so as much as i who wrote [ __ ]
mephisto
into his daredevil run i love the
characters so much as much as i would
like to believe
oh [ __ ] mitz mephisto i don't i don't
think it is mephisto
um for what it's worth but that's what's
fun about this show
is [ __ ] theorizing and speculating
they were brilliant
to not [ __ ] drop ten episodes or nine
episodes at once
like it forces conversation every week
it if we were able to watch this all in
one clip we would have been done
talking about this like a [ __ ] tiger
king minute ago and stuff
but because they're portioning it out
like they did with mandalorian and
taking us back to old tv
like every week you get excited for it
every week it owns [ __ ] twitter for
like from
friday morning at 12 a.m until [ __ ]
monday
um and it's it makes me excited about
chapter reading again this reminds me of
[ __ ] reading comic books again
because like unlike the marvel movies
which are like here's one every six
months or something like that
we've been getting a marvel movie every
week now
in in smaller doses but still
so you know it's just like the comic
book experience and as much as like
oh i'm [ __ ] done but instead of
having to wait till next month you only
have to wait till
next week yeah it's a thing that that
that hulu
did i mean granted television has been
doing this
for 75 years which is like
oh every week you get a new episode but
hulu you know i think with with
first with handmaid's tale and then
later with castle rock
they sort of they they got really good
at that we'll give you three episodes
first or two episodes first and then
week by week
you know and i was always a fan of that
as a as a
former journalist realizing the if
nothing else
the marketing potential of doing that
which is you get people talking about it
every week you get people recapping it
every week
whereas if you're gonna just like hey we
put queen's gambit and it's great
we love it but we're only talking about
it once like once you finish watching
and same with the stranger things like
we love it to death
we talk about it once you saw it all
right yeah moving on
but now it's this it's the water cooler
you know finding ways to recreate
that like hey man did you [ __ ] see
lost last week oh [ __ ] that was nuts
what's gonna happen next week i don't
[ __ ] know but that's great
and i love that about tv you know more
than i love that you know about almost
any other medium
except for maybe comics you know we do
it once a week
it's so crazy we're so used to a culture
now
in in everything but but entertainment
of course
where it's like you want it now here you
want it all here
and you know oh we're done what's next
now here here's another thing
um the fact that
you know somebody's like you just gotta
wait
a week and then we'll give you a little
more
introduces discipline to the media diet
that hasn't existed for quite some time
i mean you're you're definitely right to
credit hulu um but for me it was
disney plus you know like it's
mandalorian it's
it's uh wanda vision where you know i'm
like hey man what do you mean
[ __ ] one at a time what are you crazy
and you know i i at first you know
chafed against it but it's part of the
magic
it's part of the [ __ ] fun like
i nothing like and this is you know such
a first world sentiment believe me
there are things in life more
disappointing than this i promise you
but the moment
the credits roll it feels like nothing
is more disappointing in the world than
like oh
like it's done no and then but like
i can't remember the last time except
for mandalorian that i was
excited for like a [ __ ] friday this
literally recreated fridays for me where
you know back in the day
when i was a kid when you were a kid
[ __ ] fridays were everything and then
you become an adult and you're like
it's another [ __ ] day they're all
terrible this
[ __ ] made friday special again where
it's like
i got some [ __ ] to look forward to
particularly in an era where
movies used to come out on friday and we
haven't had that in a [ __ ] year man
like
everything has really come around in a
great way
for one division like you know i don't
know
i love it and i think it's amazing and
it's breakthrough
but like if the world was moving at the
pace that it used to move
would it slow down for this um
you know it's marvel so definitely but
think about it like
every all the conditions are right we
were starved for a marvel
anything for like a year at that point
by the time it came
and so when it came like it's not just
an
inconsequential like hey this is [ __ ]
sort of tied to some [ __ ] you like
it literally is moving the ball forward
in a way that we all thought
oh they'd only do that in a movie
there's no way they would bring the
mutants in through a [ __ ] tv show
they're not going to bring fantastic
four in through a tv show and
they literally had had [ __ ] monica
rambo say
i think it was monica rambo say she's
creating reality
like that is the key to the multiverse i
mean we know the multiverse exists but
if wanda has like phoenix like god-like
[ __ ] powers man
and if we've seen [ __ ] an x-man
at the end of this episode whether or
not it turns out he's plucked from the x
universe we don't [ __ ] know
but the sky is the limit at this point
they
it's not like you know in days of old
with a tv show that was remotely
connected to
a [ __ ] uh movie franchise you didn't
see anything like this
think about x-files when x-files did
their big [ __ ] tie-in movie remember
it was almost inconsequential to the
rest of the [ __ ] series
like so much so that if you didn't see
that movie you could have kept watching
the next season
this they're making a series where
they're
like you know they're like normally we
do this in movie theaters where we do
change our entire universe in a film but
we're doing it on this this is how
[ __ ] important how serious we're
treating this
what is what what a [ __ ] uh a
a breakthrough piece of media we're
creating here
that we're willing to [ __ ] put all of
our eggs
into this [ __ ] basket and assume that
you're gonna [ __ ] keep following the
story and they're absolutely [ __ ]
right
i think they're pulling more people in
with wanda vision i thought at the
beginning
addis is like you know you got to be a
fan to get all this but i think it's
such compelling storytelling
they're pulling in [ __ ] new people i
know it for a fact
every week i watch my wife go like let's
go she she
never [ __ ] lined up for marvel man
and now every week she's standing for
stan
so they're doing some wonderful things
over there yeah i mean i do wonder
to your point if we weren't in the
pandemic if this wouldn't be
a thursday show or a sunday show
you know like because yes why why make
new competition for yourself
if you don't have to like yes we people
are going to the movies friday and
saturday nights let's not do it then
we'll do another night where we know
they'll be home like hbo used to be the
sunday night jam
because they knew that's when you'd be
around and waiting for something else so
yeah game of thrones sopranos
oz sex in the city you know all of it
will spool out on a sunday
now days are they don't matter what's
today
just like tomorrow but but yet
disney plus has now redefined a friday
for me where i'm like oh i know when
friday is that's when the good [ __ ]
happens
i just have to live until friday at 12
a.m that's what i [ __ ] tell myself
every week you just hold on till [ __ ]
friday at 12 a.m technically 1am because
that's when
you could watch the show twice which i
do as soon as it's over i go right back
[ __ ] watch it again then i watch the
[ __ ] big highlight moments and stuff
and there were plenty big highlight
moments in this episode
uh we saw them almost come to [ __ ]
blows man
vision and the scarlet witch yes very
peter pan
suspended in the air yes and it's like
like in terms of a special effect not
that special
lifting people up but used
perfectly to the point where you're like
that was [ __ ]
big i mean honestly like it's not
other than how they're shooting the
shows you know in the production value
they're not [ __ ] going crazy with the
special effects
it's compelling storytelling that's
getting you from point
to point you know and now i think we're
actually going to see
a lot more special effects as we've seen
in the trailers
him turning into vision her like the
vision we all know
from the costume vision uh her flying
you know
looking like she's going into battle and
[ __ ] like that
um things will probably get
progressively bigger the scene where she
comes out
of the hex as dark darcy now calls it
you know looked like an expensive
[ __ ] movie scene
all them trucks all them lights all them
[ __ ] lasers pointed at her and [ __ ]
like that
yeah i mean i was looking at the let's
talk about that scene though
is that
nothing in the marvel cinematic universe
ever seems to be an accident
there's no way it was an accident that
she did
what magneto did in the first x-men
movie
do you think that was intentional do you
think that's a
foreshadowing moment um i mean it's it's
for sure
intentional you know because you know
and and i think you know it as well as
anybody
very little happens at that scale
by accident you know like anything if it
is by accident it then becomes
intentional
by virtue of like you kept in the movie
like you kept it on tv
um so yeah i think it's definitely you
know on purpose
um that same evocation even though it's
not she's not using magnet power she's
using mind control powers but still
um whether that's foreshadowing you know
the eventuality that
in this world magneto's her dad um
[Music]
which itself is a retcon in the comic
books like his her dad was maxum off and
not actually
lent sure um but it is super [ __ ]
cool
you know because that's that's what
power looks like you know and i think
that's
you know that's that's how it was used
in the first x-men movie which is yeah
your puny weapons mean nothing to me
and here it's your mind is my play thing
and i can make it do what i needed to do
which includes and in entails
everything um
both of them vision and the scarlet
witch
um were made by the mine stone correct
um yes
because the same [ __ ] the thing
that's in his head
was in the tesseract pokey stick
the tesseract and that's what they were
using to experiment on
wanda yes um
and she destroyed it in infinity war
she destroyed the mind stone and then
thanos brought it back together and
stole the mind stone
right and he has a mind stone
in this world you think
she makes it i mean
how to unmake a mind stone and in a
world where like monica said she's
creating reality
is it possible she's reproduced an
infinity stone
it is but you know it's also you know
what is animating vision does not need
to be the mind stone
because clearly it's just wanda because
in some fashion
she's given her vibrator new batteries
um
clearly um how awesome was the and also
once again
not expensive because they did most of
it on video monitor
but how awesome was her [ __ ] breaking
end to sword and stealing vision's body
and they called him a synthazoid as well
where you're like
and also what were they doing with his
body you know it looked
like it was now their name is what is it
sentient weapon
yeah so that's what they were doing with
his body he was a living weapon at one
point but it looked like
there were people experimenting i mean
his body didn't seem to be in like cold
storage somewhere
no and so it was in many pieces
yeah so like that uh whatever his name
is the the acting director of sword
who was like yeah no she was in vision's
living will that he wouldn't be brought
back to life he didn't want to be used
as a weapon to anybody else
sword is experimenting on that dude
probably trying to figure out how to
make another one
and so the high horse of that guy just
to claim that uh that wanda was being a
terrorist
by uh by stealing vision's body it's
like yeah you guys weren't playing up
and up either
um the uh on the on the talkback
a couple questions uh chris says i think
those commercials are wanda's parents
that seems to be the general consensus
of the internet thus far is that
the same man and woman are in every one
of those commercials the latest
one was for lagos you know for [ __ ]
spills and looked like a bloody spill on
the counter and [ __ ] like that
um yeah so yes i think we all agree to
that
um mozartistic one says can we discuss
vision becoming aware of what's going on
yes that was awesome
the moment where he [ __ ] pulls norm
out of it norm is like it hurts i'm
scared
yeah my wife was sick where's my phone
like all i want to do is get i don't
know where i am where where are we
where's my stuff
and him getting like starting to freak
out and stuff like that and you know
which coupled nicely with the moment
we saw on the trailer over and over
again where agnes
you know goes should we go back to the
top because vision does something
slightly off script where he's like i
don't want to roll the babies
and then she looks at wanda lost as if
wanda is either the actress or the
director
um going like should we should we go
back to the top and
then you know [ __ ] like isn't that
weird and
wanda's covering for her and then at one
point [ __ ] agnes sprays some [ __ ] on
the kids who go from babies to suddenly
being able to grow themselves
wanda's magic doesn't affect the kid she
tries to put them to sleep and [ __ ] but
they still cry and whatnot
so i wonder i mean there's
they just keep layering [ __ ] it's
it's like a frito pie a mystery
just layer upon layer of wonderful
content every [ __ ] episode they keep
doing it
um the uh
the uh i lost the question i had
um i heard an interesting theory a buddy
of mine uh
dan evans thought that the each
commercial
is keyed to a particular infinity stone
so the toaster is his vision and the
mind stone the watch is the time stone
the box of soap is the tesseract the
lagos towels
is the ether for when you make a mess
you didn't mean to
and you know there's there's four more
episodes which means that there's you
know
one more than uh you know it's got two
more than we have infinity stones
but still i was like oh that's
interesting i like that theory
i buy that theory i co-sign that
um here talk some more i'm sorry i got
to deal with something real quick say
something smart about the show
um i i
i will say i remember being on on star
trek
and my boss at the time you know we were
talking about
you know bringing in characters from you
know other series and crossovers and
basically it's the appeal and the
deployment of nostalgia
as as story as opera as operative story
and the idea was always like we can't
just use a character because
deep fans will remember remember and
recognize it
it has to have an actual legit um
story purpose we can hear you texting
all right yeah let me put my press mute
i'm gonna try to put out a small fire
here go
oh small fires um so like while i
appreciated seeing uh pietro
um quicksilver in in this one i wanted
it to be
more than that you know like just seeing
that dude's face
doesn't necessarily mean something if
you don't know who that guy
is you know or if you don't know that
that guy is a is a quicksilver
from a different franchise that it
doesn't imply
the crossing of streams the opening of
multiverses which
is cool if you know and i and i and i
dug it for that
but i wanted there to be something more
i wanted him to mean something more
to vision and to an audience that didn't
know
um but i still thought it was kind of
cool i thought it was cool but i just
needed
i just needed it to have some context
that made it worth
that big bum bum moment
um yeah i guess there's that aspect of
course like
you know i did have to explain to
jennifer you know she's like because i
was like
you know the when they revealed evan
peters and you know which also allowed
me to be like well let me show you
courtesy of disney plus
um you know him in action as quicksilver
in
uh that first uh in the x the first
x-men movie that he was in days of
future past
so you know it'd be not everyone gets
that huge moment
if unless you're like an ardent viewer
of not just the marvel movies but the
x-men movies
as well going way back and stuff but
it's small
price to pay you know what i'm saying
like i remember [ __ ] watching
dallas or dynasty with my mother and my
mother going
at certain moments and maybe i'm going
like i don't understand because i didn't
watch the show every week and she'd be
like well that's [ __ ]
jr and her were doing it and whatever
[ __ ] so like you know sometimes you got
to hold somebody's hand a little bit
right like i thought it's a cool moment
but just as this big
momentous blow off the episode
it just felt you needed to be deep in
the club
to have that moment mean anything um
which you know i suppose by episode five
of this show
they're they're banking on the fact that
you are
deep in the club i feel like they're
right i mean granted my
google news algorithm like you know
shows me on
[ __ ] that i'm interested in stuff but
then i switch over to just trending
topics
and wanda vision you know tends to be
trending
all the [ __ ] time over the weekend
people talking about it and granted you
know there are a lot of marvel fans on
the internet and stuff but
i'm telling you you can't just be my
wife who's like oh i never watch this
[ __ ] but i am watching this [ __ ] i think
they're catching
a lot more people i think they're going
to catch emmy attention i think like not
only is the show going to wind up
getting nominated for awards and stuff
but i think there's no chance in hell
elizabeth olsen doesn't get nominated
she's just so [ __ ] wonderful and
we're gonna watch her slowly
unravel we're starting to see it in
places you know the veneer is cracking
um and so what a what a gift like for
for her as an actress with that
character you know who like
got cool scenes in a bunch of movies but
you know this is her showcase and
um and boy is she up for the challenge
of pulling off the
the the stuff that they're handing her
man she's a great actress he's wonderful
as well
yeah um you know i mean i number one
he's just so
infinitely listenable with a british
accent classy british accent
but number two you forget that like you
know this guy
paul bettany's been there since the
beginning of the marvel cinematic
universe part of the [ __ ] dna
of the marvel cinematic universe that's
why i wonder man if like you know
there's the big story that came out this
week where some journalists
asked elizabeth olsen is there anything
coming
that's luke skywalker in the mandalorian
huge
and she's indicated yes she didn't say
that herself like there's something this
[ __ ] huge but she indicated
huge things were coming and so that lit
the internet on fire and everybody's
been speculating
i myself speculated that it might be
thanos uh being that she's about history
with [ __ ] thanos like you know would
it be a weird thing if he showed up in
an episode
but now i'm starting to think
like vision is tied directly into
tony stark is it possible
i mean that's that's where my head goes
because the thing that vision
the big piece of information the vision
doesn't have is that tony stark is dead
like his father his progenator this
creator
the man for whom we begin this entire
story with
is gone and vision doesn't know it and
if that you know synthezoid has a heart
anywhere buried beneath the vibranium
wires and whatever
that would break it in two and he
doesn't seem to know
his history yes to know everything about
her and him and they have these
abilities and stuff like that
but he doesn't seem to have any
recollection of being
an avenger or you know i guess we're
gonna see that
in the next episode which is the uh
you know we kept stinging in all the
trailers when he wakes up agnes i don't
think i'm spoiling anything it's been
there since the beginning where she's
like oh my god you're the avengers or
whatever the [ __ ]
so right now it doesn't seem like he
like knows that he was part of the
avengers doesn't seem to know that there
are other
heroes has he referenced anybody else
um i mean i think he he might have
acknowledged
ultron when geraldine
no he wasn't in the scene when geraldine
talks about it so no
think about it he's never once
referenced
the marvel cinematic universe he's
referenced their universe
you know in one division but never right
he mentioned itself
and because this week get very
frustrated where he's like i can't
remember
and that's about bettany but you know
what i was going for and like he doesn't
know
that they're not married you know like
as far as he knows
is all he knows is westview all he knows
is that you know he's her husband and
she's his wife and they have these two
children
and that's all that according to her he
needs to know
he says that he can't remember anything
before westview
yeah maybe this is the week he remembers
by talking to agnes when she says you're
an avenger or whatever the [ __ ] like
so yeah and in that instance i mean do
you think like we've like even
like think i mean
we know that this show is being produced
relatively close to the time that we're
watching it
it's not like they're all done when they
started they're they're
not too far behind more or less and
they're certainly not reacting in real
time the show's too big
but like you know let's say
when they started you know they
didn't have a tony stark level cameo
lined up
and then after [ __ ] mandalorian and
luke
they were like [ __ ] we gotta we gotta
draw big
or go [ __ ] home go big or go home and
maybe it's something that
came later down the line i don't know
i'm at this point literally we're just
[ __ ]
being yes you see theorists but
i i could see a world where if we don't
see tony stark we at least hear tony
stark
and i don't mean old tony stark i mean
maybe new tony stark
maybe all things are possible
i mean wasn't he just in the news
recently about some [ __ ]
i mean he did say something to the
effect
i remember some you know interview
whatever he's like you know i don't know
if i'm entirely done done done but
um you know never say never to marvel i
think is what he said but i think he
also said tony stark is dead
um yes and tony stark can still be dead
and show up in one division yes indeed
everybody's dead and it's showing up in
wonderful very very true
um once again they're [ __ ] just
making life worth living
over there marvel god bless kevin feige
the only kevin
we need to save at all costs every kevin
is expendable
every kevin hart
i'm talking about kevin smith except for
kevin
feige that's the only kevin that [ __ ]
matters in this sick old world
making magic over it marble god bless
you
uh juan division that's what we've
bought and that's what we thought ladies
and gentlemen
now we move on to i bet you some news
because mark
he's got the news in his blood he's an
old news hound and stuff
and so even though he retired from the
land of news and as you hear he's a
creative he's writing comic books [ __ ]
working on secret [ __ ] he can't tell you
about working on
tv shows and [ __ ] like that but he can't
get that stink of the news off him
unless he uses native deodorant
nativedeo.com ladies and gentlemen i'm
gonna get the stinking news off you
used to call it fat man at checkout
think of the old news that you
native o dot com slash fatman uh mark's
an old news man and so he brought some
news for you mark what's this week's
news
um you know back into the world of
marvel because it's a world that
you know we a can't escape and be have
no desire to we want to stay there
i don't want to stay there and they are
endeavoring to make sure that we do
because ryan coogler black panther
filmmaker has just signed
a massive five-year overall deal with
disney part of which
is developing a world of wakanda disney
plus tv show
i so smart so so [ __ ] smart like i'm
sure
they've been you know trying to figure
out what their plans are going to be
for another black panther movie now that
sadly chadwick boseman is gone
this would certainly buy them a lot of
time to like
go play in the world of wakanda without
having to like we gotta
make a movie now without our main
character and stuff
but even if they do them side by side
even if they're making a black panther
two right now and making this series
later
it's a brilliant idea yeah i mean it's a
great location
it allows for like the imagination runs
wild we saw only pieces of it
um and you know there's so much more
they could dive into and [ __ ]
i'd watch a [ __ ] all shuri's show
but i'm sure we're not gonna get that
but uh i i i'm all for it i thought i
read this [ __ ] i was like
chef's kiss that's fantastic yeah i mean
he's he's actively writing
the next the the next black panther
film which is supposed to start shooting
you know later this year
um and is due out july 8th 2022 with
release date
so like it's moving it's happening but
that idea that the gay wakanda
is a relatively big place we've only
ever just seen like
the capital city of wakanda and we've
only ever met a handful of characters
and even if you were going to do just
black panthers there's a thousand years
worth of black panther stories to tell
that don't have to involve t'challa
i just want to point out to kabuki kid
in the talkbacks he said
jeff's kiss
it ain't no jeff's kiss all right chefs
kiss chefs kiss yes but if it's if it's
jeff bridges
i will also give that man a kiss that's
true man [ __ ] you don't mind [ __ ]
jeff's kiss when it comes from [ __ ]
dude you do to buy dude
um yeah i can't wait man and [ __ ]
he's such a good storyteller i just i
just rewatched creed for no good reason
the other day
just because you could it's a [ __ ]
it's just a wonderful movie like
you can see like you know why he did
such a great job on
black panther he entered a universe and
told the story in universe with black
panther
you know he did the same thing with
[ __ ] creed he entered the universe
and told the story
in universe and you know is one of the
best [ __ ] stories they've told
in that universe since the very first
story they ever told in that universe
yeah you know and it's and it takes
these moments like i love creed
you know because it just there's it's so
much about the relationship between
tessa thompson's character and and
michael b jordan's character
and so much of that is just quiet so
much of that is just like
him taking her braids out and having a
conversation about what they want about
the future
and yeah when you get in the ring it's
awesome and visceral and you're right
there
next to [ __ ] donnie um but it's
there's so much love and care given to
to telling those character stories
which is yeah you get that dude to do
whatever he wants to do and you pay him
handsomely to do it
agreed agreed pay him everything um
that is fantastic news god it just makes
me
want to watch creed again and i
literally just went
you're absolutely right they're like
they're like the romance between
those two is moving compelling
quiet organic very real
like don't feel like the movie romance
and stuff and it has easily
you know not easy but one could easily
say it's got
movie [ __ ] romance tropes going on
and stuff but
very believable and and honestly like
one of the most interesting things about
a movie that's packed with [ __ ]
interesting things
a movie that's technically a rocky
sequel and one of the most interesting
aspects of it is those two in their
relationship but
that's because you got two fantastic
[ __ ] actors pulling it off he's a
[ __ ]
amazing kid who was amazing way back in
the day and she's fantastic
in literally [ __ ] everything i got my
wife to watch [ __ ] thor
ragnarok like go figure man she was like
because i was like just got kate
blanchett and she was like all right
and then she had seen the valkyrie
character in endgame and stuff
like who's that so i was like oh you get
to meet valkyrie here and then she's got
the big [ __ ] opening scene where she
rocks the guns and kills everybody
and jennifer was like oh i'm in i'm like
even better than that
i was like she becomes the king of
asgard and then
i was like that's later down the road
so um yeah man [ __ ] i'm off
i was just gonna jump in the reason
you're watching creed might be
that the composer from the mandalorian
ludwig gorensen is the
guy who composed all the music and creed
is that right
so if you were still riding the
mandalorian train
it may have just subconsciously taken
you into creed
gotta fly now i'm sure i can mash up
[ __ ] the rocky theme and the
mandalorian theme and
the creed theme but i'm not that
talented i did see this thing on youtube
where you know they played the
mandalorian theme
as you just very adequately and expertly
uh did a cover of
but also inside of it like the dude was
playing a keyboard whatever like mental
theme and then right in the middle of it
all of the star wars themes like here's
the imperial march here's the throne
room scene here's whatever
and all of it works because gorenson was
working in the same
sort of modality and key structure and
and note structure and chord structure
as john williams was you know like he's
that [ __ ]
deep nerd about it which is it needs to
feel star wars but it needs to be its
own thing
and you know how it feels star wars
because if you play star wars it feels
like it's part of it
i thought that was fascinating grace
haven in the chat
said kevin the world has been gregg
because of you do you know what gregging
is
have you ever heard that term um no but
i hope it
requires consent is that like uh [ __ ]
like jeff's kiss
[Laughter]
what does that mean is anyone what does
the term correct mean i want to give
jeff a kiss as anthony perrone
the dude from clerks that's right jeff
anderson uh
jeffrey davis says greg zit but i mean
what is that mean the greg
what is it well i got to read that again
i was real like
wow i'm responsible for gregging what
does that mean
what does that mean what does that mean
i don't really know
um and maybe i shouldn't know
maybe it's panda forever says berlanti
mike d says old greg drinks baileys from
a shoe
[Laughter]
um all is greg says human hyperbole
come on man and now they're [ __ ] just
making [ __ ] up yeah
gainable goes it means you got old gregg
greg all right spiderman says greg a
person
is gregg if they're both excessively
drunk
and acting in a co a comically
inappropriate matter
is that [ __ ] manner is that right i've
never heard of that
yeah and how are you responsible for
that i don't know
but boy oh boy i've been [ __ ] kissing
jeff and i've now i've been gregged
frost diaz says san antonio loves that
kevin reference frito pie let me tell
you something i [ __ ] love frito pie
and it's
like if you use vegan cheese you can
make a vegan frito pie so
i'm on board fritos vegan as [ __ ] only
three ingredients in a frito
corn oil salt bam you got a freedom
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry i'm dragging out here man i'm
totally dragging it
i i did not expect this to suddenly be
like the cooking channel
let me tell you man [ __ ] corn salt
oil that's all you need that's a good
time baby
you put that [ __ ] in there you got a
stew baby remember [ __ ]
arrested development oh well there's
just like
you got a bone you got some broth you
got a stew baby
man you just made yourself a [ __ ]
chili ski just smoke that [ __ ] right
into your face everybody wins
um sean cisco says fritos is a sponsor
now
i wish i wish we had some of that
frito-lay money are you kidding me
this show we had some free money we'd be
on [ __ ] television
never mind the internet oh hell yes
you got gregg [ __ ] you got greg
that feels like the like the punch line
of the anal vice
detectives you got greg you got gregg'd
jeff's kiss because one of the
vice detective's name is jeff of course
whenever he [ __ ]
whenever they put a criminal down he's
like that's a great bus
partner and he goes jeff's kiss you got
greg
uh greg was stoned says samina yappa
i don't know if that's it
again not a thing you can be responsible
for
so true um all right what other news we
got
uh more marvel um we everything
marvel just keep all the marvel make it
all marvel news [ __ ] marvel news
um you and i and i think the rest of the
nerd world was very excited when it was
announced that mahershala ali would be
playing
the day walker blade um
and yes i'm i continue to be incredibly
excited that this is going to happen and
now we are one step closer to it
happening
because they've officially hired a
writer to write the blade film
who is it a woman named stacy oseka4
who was uh on she's been on watchmen you
know that little thing
that's a great pedigree come off
watchmen [ __ ] not
great buddy come off watchman [ __ ] yeah
you know and
amazon's hunters and the hulu series pin
15.
um oh [ __ ] that's a diversified [ __ ]
resume that means they'll get some
action they'll get some funny
words they'll get some you know [ __ ]
well-rounded indeed you know and uh if
if looking at her resumes of anything
she's got an emmy under her
under her belt um
for watchmen watchman which didn't mean
yes
um but when asking for writing everybody
that wrote on it wins an emmy
um if the specific episode yes
i mean the writer of that specific
episode gets an emmy but then if it's
you know if it wins for best you know
drama or best miniseries or whatever
i believe if you're a producer or above
you get an enemy for that as well
um or at the very least you can say i
worked on the emmy winning
watchman which is also true so weird i
never
like you know when i first got into the
business
like i got into the business on the
[ __ ] uh
indie film end and stuff where awards
and
criticism like getting good critical
notices were like important and stuff
like that
so the beginning of my career and this
is not me lamenting one
one iota whatsoever but at the beginning
of my career like i won awards
for the movies that i made and stuff it
was so weird because that was not the
intent i was never like i'm hoping to
make a ward worthy film
um but you know
those days are long gone and i don't
ever
like i don't have that in me where i'm
like oh man i would like to win
like one of those what does one have to
do to like win that and stuff like i
just like i'm i'm happy when i hear
people one and stuff but
oddly enough like awards never did it
for me and probably because like i never
considered anything i do like [ __ ]
remotely award-worthy and stuff but
it's so not a part of my makeup
you know like if i like i think the next
award if i ever get another award it'll
probably be like
here's the posthumous he was an
all-right guy award that they give out
[ __ ] maybe the gold's glow
or some [ __ ] but yeah it's it's so
you're does that help like does that you
you've got more of an ear to the ground
and a finger on the pulse of the
writer's game uh is that like
does that raise your stations you get
paid more if you win an emmy
it i think it does two things it gets
you meetings you might not ordinarily
have been able to get it gets you into
rooms that you might not be able to get
previously
and yeah you can bump your quote like
yeah i got a [ __ ] emmy that is worth
x you know if you're a director or a
screenwriter of features that is worth
whatever it's also a thing they can now
use to
sell the fact that you're on this movie
this is from oscar winner so forth and
so on
um but you said she worked on watchmen i
was like oh watchman
yeah it's like every actor who is on the
wire will always get meetings
similarly because you were on the
[ __ ] wire you know it's like you did
20 years ago but yeah
[ __ ] i'm sure that somebody will be
in a room with interest elba and ask
about playing string a bell
you know like if you do that work that
that is sort of rewarded by the
establishment
and held in esteemed by your peers that
will do a little something for you
and as huge as he was as stringer bell
and
it broke him [ __ ] massive and created
him as a
you know the the rising star that he he
was and now he's a [ __ ]
huge international star so weird i
rarely ever think of him as stringer
bell anymore
he's done so much work that like
you know that that which is one of his
most compelling roles
i you know i don't even it doesn't cross
my mind that often but yeah you're right
he goes right back to the [ __ ] wire
man
yeah i mean which is which is great that
he's had the capacity and the ability to
be able to stretch and
and be more than that because you know
when sean connery won an oscar
after having not played james bond for
30 years
they still played the [ __ ] james bond
theme song when he went out to collect
his oscar
it's like there are certain things and
certain people for whom you will always
imagine them as the first thing you saw
them in um
and it's like you know in terms of i
just had a real flash of like at first i
thought it was uh
what i call that white privilege but
then i realized it's not so much white
privilege as it is
um what would i call it
because it ain't about being white but i
i've never had pro i can get a meeting
with
almost anybody i could pitch anywhere
but
it don't mean they buy but like so
that's why i don't ever you know i only
i for me it was never a big big deal to
get into a room because
it's not like that ever got me something
you know what i'm saying like
it's but i've had no problems getting
into a room
and then for a minute when you were
talking about like that emmy gets people
into a room
i was like oh [ __ ] and then for a second
i was like oh that's my white privilege
where i'm like well i just get into
rooms
but i don't think it is white privilege
i think that's clerk's privilege
like i'm still eating out on [ __ ]
clerks 27 years later bro
like that i still get meetings like
people
and on one level it's kind of a waste of
time i guess because
they're not really gonna take what
you're pitching unless it's like
the most brilliant idea and let's be
honest i haven't had those in a long
time
so generally you wind up meeting with a
bunch of people who are just like oh my
god i love clerks
and so you know i get into rooms i
realize right now that like
it's that more than anything else um
it's just like
you were part of something that was a
part of my world before i did all this
and you know the least i could do is sit
down and
talk to you yeah i remember there was
about two years ago
i i was developing a tv show
that at the time was hopefully going to
star
sylvester stallone um which was
ridiculous and awesome and i got to have
a couple meetings with sly and it was so
much fun
and surreal in every way you imagine be
surreal and then for like
you know after sly was like listen i
don't think i want to star on this
that's you know tv is a lot of work and
you know i i can be like a guest star or
whatever but like i'll produce it for
you
um if that'll help it's like you know
we'd be great in this car weathers would
be great
as you're [ __ ] as your star and it's
like yeah
for every reason possible but also
there's no meeting you can't get
if you're walking into a room with like
rocky balboa
and apollo creed to pitch a tv show
like that for that same reason you won't
be pitching to junior execs
you'd be pitching to the head of the
network probably the head of the company
for sure like i'm pitching to whatever
japanese guy actually owns sony
you know we're like oh no no no we're
we're past you know
whatever white dude is running this
studio now we're going straight
to tokyo and uh and half that pitch is
going to be like
taking pictures with [ __ ] rocky and
apollo
i have i i'm telling you i've gone i
remember when i was pitching maul rats
too
and i got to go everywhere i stopped
going at a certain point because it got
disconcerting but like they were all
happy to be like you know
heavy in and be like oh my god i [ __ ]
love mall rats man i remember watching
that
my friends and blah blah and then i rock
them with like all right well here's
small rats too and to be fair
what i eventually wound up writing as
mall rats too was not the mall rats 2
that i pitched to all those cats
but like once i started pitching like
mall rats too
like all that joy of oh my god i [ __ ]
love maul rats
goes away cause they're like oh [ __ ] i
gotta
i gotta let this guy down cause i ain't
making [ __ ] maul rats too
you know like that was [ __ ] fine when
i was 16 years old but i got
because my job hangs in the balance
i've seen that expression i've been in
that meeting many times where i'm like
oh i get it and
i don't take offense i'm not like well
why did you waste my time
and get out or something like i'm just
[ __ ] happy to be in a room i'll be
honest with you like one of my favorite
jobs i ever got
never wound up like becoming anything um
but
the kingdom keepers show that i was
gonna do a disney plus before disney
plus became
you know the mandalorian and the marvel
shows which was kind of bore sweet
um but you know those shows are so good
i don't give a [ __ ] that they didn't do
the kingdom keepers show but like i went
into that pitch
so like you know i'm never getting this
[ __ ] job
so i could just go in like a human being
instead of like you know let me try to
dazzle these folks
and so i went in like with my laptop
and i was like look instead of pitching
can i just read you what i wrote
it's a 16-page document but i'll go
fast and i'll look up and make eye
contact but like
would you mind if i did that and they
were like yeah go that'd be great go
ahead
and i got that job and like that was one
of the greatest jobs i ever had him you
know
sad the show didn't go forward but um
it's a concept that's one day it's time
will come
favreau tried to do the you know disney
after dark movie and then we were trying
to do the after dark
tv series and stuff sooner or later
somebody's going to [ __ ] do it so
they're going to be like
now would have been the time with
[ __ ] disneyland being closed
look at it it's all yours got a set
sitting right there wide open and [ __ ]
but um the the like
expectation i had walking into that room
was like
never getting this [ __ ] job and i got
that job same thing with masters in the
universe
like when i talked to the mattel folks
about massive universe i was like i have
no
nobody's going to give me a [ __ ]
masters universe show to run
so i'll just [ __ ] be myself and say
what i would do with the masters
universe show
and i got that job the key to this is
like
never overthink it you you don't
you're you don't have the job don't even
think you're ever gonna get the job
and then you go in at this weird place
of like zen
where you're like all right maybe you
know i'm
now with zoom pitches it's even easier
because i don't even have to think about
like oh man i [ __ ] took a shower
and i [ __ ] got my car and i had to
drive 45 minutes to [ __ ] santa monica
and then [ __ ] watch that plane face
[ __ ] like
not show me anything when i told him the
greatest
[ __ ] idea in the world [ __ ] this
business that's all gone
because now it's just like you know boop
hey man so here's my
pitch and you're out in 10 minutes and
you don't buy it you're like whatever i
didn't leave my office
and then you're back to smoking weed and
it's all [ __ ] good
yeah i've decided to start approaching
these meetings um
with what i have to assume is the same
level of
mine as well as like you know and i and
i do not in any
me in any way mean to cast aspersions on
the two fellas who did game of thrones
but they had never run a tv show before
they did game of thrones
like they there was no oh like
[ __ ] guys like i'm sorry we can't give
it to you because you've never won a tv
show we're not gonna give you
the biggest tv show in the history of
the world they went in they pitched the
story they wanted to tell they pitched
to george
or martin first then pitched hbo and
they said yeah go make a show
and like that's now how i've decided to
start approaching [ __ ] which is you know
what
and they made a show for a good six
seasons
and then they stopped making a show
well you're absolutely right like those
cats were not they didn't
it's not like they were like look at my
greg berlanti sized dick and my huge
empire tv shows and [ __ ]
they had never run a show before and
they're like can we make a 15 million
dollar per episode tv show please and
they're like okay
and off they went yes so i am now
enduring every
meeting with that level of you know and
it's not hubris it's like
[ __ ] it why not i mean
you know what do they say fake it so you
can make it those dudes are just like
yeah dragons swords we could do it and
then they were like all right
here's all the money in the world and
they were like
i'm gonna do this now that's the worst
part man
getting the job is hard enough and then
when they're like all right do it you're
like [ __ ]
yeah i remember the first time i ever
sold anything um this this pilot script
that i'd written
that eventually got sold to warner
brothers
you know i sold it and then my wife was
like why are you not more happy
and i was like well because now it's
real like
at some point somebody will want me to
make more of these and then i have to do
that
like ah yeah she's like but it's what
you want oh no i know i'm happy
but the reality of it is dawning on me
in a way i didn't expect it to
so damn true yes um
all right what else we got more news and
i think this one will be resonant in a
way
um to both of us um
it's the title that i wrote down is buck
rogers in a battle against
chain of the title
which is the buck rogers estate has
fired a cease and desist letter to
legendary about their recent development
of a tv reboot of
buck rogers uh the george clooney and
his smokehouse partner grant hessler for
the executive produce and brian cave on
his writing
apparently the buck rogers his interests
have already penned an agreement with
skydance
to exploit the property be advised that
buck roger's interests have
blah blah blah blah your conduct is
slander of title of the rights of the
buck rogers interest owned
demand is made that you correct the
record publicity as legendary murphy
have no chain of title
you are directed to advise all third
parties including and insurers
distributors and financers that is no
chain of title held by legendary
or don murphy who's also producing
ah the fun of buck rogers kids remember
that
that adventure where buck got into
litigation
over owner chain of title ownership
this is as interesting as the opening of
[ __ ] episode one with the trade
federation
last week we had a great story about how
george clooney might be buck rogers
this week they're like not so fast sky
dance owns that why wouldn't sky dance
be like
keep [ __ ] doing it keep doing it and
then jump out
once they got a [ __ ] go picture
that's when a mom if i'm skydance i'm
like
that's when i skydance into the picture
and be like oh we'll take half
but [ __ ] now why you [ __ ] saber
and riddle and sabers now be like we own
that
[ __ ] that man i'm like george clooney's
doing it
go ahead i'll take my cut
yeah no it's not sky dance it's the like
rights owners who seem to be a little
out of touch meanwhile legendary was
like we have secured the rights we need
to proceed with our project
and the company will not comment any
further this same party has been
claiming for years they have rights that
they do not have and have been trying to
inhibit projects based on rights
they do not legally control so legendary
is like [ __ ] y'all we're going anyway
wow wow and the only way they do that is
if their lawyers are like you are
ironclad you're fine this is not
what this person says good all right so
we are going to get our [ __ ] george
clooney buck rogers movie
it seems like we are going to nobody's
blinking we're moving straight ahead
but uh you guys just find out as actor
and that kind of [ __ ] might scare him
true he's just a producer like wait
what's the title's not here
[ __ ] it i gotta get out of here i got
all that liquor money what did he sell
or buy um i said [ __ ] or vodka
you know it's tequila casamigos he's
tequila rich right he's like he's
tequila rich
he's tequila rich you know in the same
way that like the rock
is tequila rich now he's got his own
brand of tequila as well
when do we get tequila rich mark when is
our tequila sunrise
[Laughter]
oh i appreciate that long walk down that
particular
gibson michelle pfeiffer little kurt
russell
yes all right what else we got um
the director of the eternals a woman
named chloe zao
she directed nomad land yes which is
getting all kinds of awards season
all the all the love from the critics
and then all the love from the critics
is uh is making a dracula movie she is
um signing on to to universal's attempt
to
refashion dracula much in the same way i
think
that blumhouse re-fashioned invisible
men
i like it yes but her dracula project
however
will be a far cry from the more
traditional or even modern incarnations
made over the years
uh details are being kept very secret
but her version is an original
futuristic
sci-fi western themes of being on
society's fringes
um which is something that that zao was
tackled in much of her previous work
dracula's sci-fi western yes
he's just a sweet trans sexual
investigate from transsexual
transylvania
indeed um all right you know what i'll
go like [ __ ] look
universal reinvented invisible man and i
was like holy [ __ ]
man this is now these are your monster
movies this is what you do
so i'll give them the benefit of the
doubt i'll go with it not what i would
think of when i thought of you know
[ __ ] dracula
never thought i'd see the words dracula
and
this western futuristic western thing
you know whatever isn't there a movie we
talked about recently where they're
doing like just that one chapter of
dracula
yeah the last voyage of the demeter
which is based on
the crossing from carpathia into london
it's a lot of dracula out there a lot of
dracula in the air
[Applause]
i will not say another show we will now
do the thing we have been doing with
alarming frequency which is saying
goodbye to a
beloved elder um of our
of our business uh christopher plummer
this was
not coveted related though was it it
does not seem to be
um it's she was 91 years old
you know and like which is a hell of a
911
91 and had been working until the very
end
yeah you know i mean knives out was
a year ago year and a half ago mm-hmm
i remember he [ __ ] uh took spacey's
place and was all the money in the world
or whatever
um yeah he was i mean you know throw a
rock and you hit a great
christopher plummer performance even in
[ __ ] like dragnet one of my favorite
christopher plumber performers of all
time
was him uh going from orange county here
we go
a devil mask and [ __ ] uh what your name
scum citizens something
no what was it i forget um
[Music]
it was an acronym
you know what someone will [ __ ] write
it in chat pretty much
anyone remember what uh the bad guys
were called
in in uh dragnet
an incredible underrated comedy
um but yeah i mean he was tagging nagin
thank you
thank you a kill
aki legend no that was nicki logan
thank you joe jobacca wookie
wow okay what does pagan stand for
pagan uh yes christopher plummer
force of nature as an actor one of the
first actors
whose names i knew even before like mark
hamill and carrie fisher
because my mom would talk about him that
was her favorite oh i love
christopher plummer you know in the
movies and i love richard chamberlain
on tv and i was like that on tv is the
only place he's going to love you mom
yes you got a chance with one of them
yeah you got a chance one so uh he was
he was a big figure
in our house um uh and that movie was
huge
and he uh never disappointed remember he
played [ __ ]
was it mike wallace and the insider yep
he didn't look a [ __ ] thing like mike
wallace and still he pulled up
he was such a good actor mark he acted
like mike wallace and we believed it
even though he was so good
yeah he was richard he was rudyard
kipling
in the man who would be king he played
sherlock holmes opposite james mason and
murdered by decree
he played a [ __ ] klingon in star trek
that's right most of the shakespeare
that i know is from
christopher plummer as a vote as a
klingon and started like the
undiscovered country or whatever it was
to be or not to be in the original clan
yes oh my god guess who's coming to
dinner
um that was such a fantastic movie now
you i'm gonna
you can make me wanna watch to watch the
undiscovered country he was so [ __ ]
good in it oh he's great
he's great i mean yeah he was in [ __ ]
knives out
um danny collins the forger
muhammad ali's greatest fight this great
2013 um
hbo movie about um ali's supreme court
case
about allende allen padini in chat says
didn't he play ming from flash gordon
no not at all sadly that's another one
yes that's
who we've already lost we already
eulogized poor max fancy now
um but yeah he's uh he was a fantastic
actor
a pillar of uh stage and screen and
you know did just about anything he
wanted to do
like return of the pink panther sure
battle for britain
why not 12 monkeys happy to be there
inside man
done oh my god that's right he was in
[ __ ] 12 monkeys
he was not however as lionel suggests he
got messed up by kylo ren that was also
matt's one side
i mean christopher plummer had a huge
career please don't confuse any he was
not
brewmeister smith in [ __ ] strange
brew either
that was one side out that is another
julie not julie jowly old white dude
there's people out there going
christopher plummer didn't he play chess
with death
in that one [ __ ] movie no that wasn't
support
for god's sakes um what an incredible
uh talent this man was uh make it 91
years
you know what i get out of that story be
an actor
they live forever i mean
one of the things that i remember
hearing this past week was that he was
like already like 82 years old
when ridley scott was like hey man do
you want to hop on a plane to roam and
shoot 22 scenes of a movie in like a wee
week because you have to replace kevin
spacey at 82 years old he's like yes
i'll be there tomorrow and it gets on a
[ __ ] plane and goes and does it and
like
that's not easy work for anybody
let alone a man of your advanced you
know event advanced age
time was if you wanted to clean up some
[ __ ] in this business you called the
plumber
well now the plumber's not on call
anymore
you got to go to the great stage in the
sky what a massive career
what a massive life um seems to have
[ __ ] dodged all controversy as well
good for him
yeah i mean either he was a top-notch
guy
or had like was smart enough not to say
the wrong things in front of a
microphone
it is it is a talent that seems to be
fading he was never creeping up in
anybody's instagram dms talking about
eating ribs or nothing like that
christopher plummer he was just he's one
of the good ones
wasn't greggy anybody will not see his
like again i should really call my
mother she's probably heartbroken about
all this yeah
now she'll never get to marry him like
mom i don't think that was in the cards
um yes what a legend what a what a
[ __ ] great actor man
uh what a loss uh ah death mark
it comes for us all yes even for kings
even for chris plumbers the undiscovered
country from which no traveler
ever returns undiscovered country
there it is it was wordplay um
did julie andrews say anything yeah
yeah i think she went on the record just
saying what a lovely man he was
and even though christopher plummer
didn't really like sound of music
he was like i was a shakespearean
trainer actor and this was nonsense
like i had to use every bit of my talent
to imbue this character with anything
resembling humanity or depth um and he
didn't do
like almost none of his own singing like
somebody else came in and did all that
singing so for him it's like you know
come on
it's not me doing like my world's best
acting and everyone's like
that's enough bro you're captain bon
trap yeah
shut it down bro you are a [ __ ]
captain vaughn thirst trap
[Music]
that's all we want you lover you just
keep the [ __ ] water flowing
all we want is that anal vice baby
blessed my homeland forever
um great christopher plummer man good uh
good for
ryan johnson he got to work with him
like he gave him a huge [ __ ]
role at
and christopher plummer he was [ __ ]
without him he got no movie
yeah he's crucial to it and you know
[ __ ] killed it
[ __ ] killed it so yes our r.a.p rest
in peace christopher plummer
mad poe in the chat asked did we watch
soul of the dragon not yet
um i was remiss this week i watched
wanda vision but before that
i watched the same day cherry
have you seen it not yet it's on my list
wonderful the russo brothers they're the
real deal man
that it's not just like oh they know how
to make marvel movies
true [ __ ] filmmakers like and and
what a great argument for like
two heads are better than one beautiful
movie quiet epic
um the kid's great like you know i watch
him read the [ __ ] phone book
like or for toast marshmallows but he's
[ __ ] wonderful in this movie ain't
you know just spider-man cute and all
shucks he's
he's [ __ ] wonderful performance um
i i'd love the flick i couldn't believe
that's what it was i had no idea that's
what the movie was going to be it's
based on a book um
you know and basically it's about opioid
addiction
um you know at the root of it all and
you know having been i've thankfully
i've never dealt with it myself but
having
known people that have dealt with it
pretty [ __ ] close
like you know very really insanely well
made
um so watch that it's coming i saw it
early because the apple gave out like a
four-year consideration
link so i got to watch it before it pops
onto apple but it's on
i think march right yeah coming pretty
soon i guess
is that what it is march i think so
uh wow i saw it early then [ __ ] it's
good like it's
really weird those guys are [ __ ]
great filmmakers and like i mean i don't
know what's going on
if it counts for this year or next year
but like it could totally
[ __ ] get awards and they could
totally get a directing nomination like
it's
beautifully made um what else did i
watch i watched an old movie just
because we watched
you know denzel and the small things or
the little things whatever that movie is
um do you ever see him in safe house
with ryan reynolds yeah i like that
movie
it's [ __ ] good flick right like i
don't think denzel washington makes a
bad movie
i like to like choose something that i'm
like oh i would love to see that right
away but like
he's always making like pretty solid
choices with his scripts it was really
totally watchable flick that was that
was part of his uh
like old man meets young white dude
serious like there's a whole mess of
those like un was unstoppable the train
will be
fine that one which i love and like
they're almost always tony scott movies
because i think that was also his jam
there's two guns with him and mark
wahlberg
um and yeah and safe house which is
success totally fun
it's [ __ ] like denzel doing like cool
action old man's [ __ ]
with a young you know a variation just a
very deep variation of the equalizer
like but in as much as he's a i was
trained to kill
but i i will i can watch the equalizer
like [ __ ] all day long like any
like sometimes in the morning i get i
just sit here on youtube and watch
equalizer clips
both one and two it's just so fun when
they [ __ ] let him fight and he looks
at people and he's all calm and just
takes people out like
systematically oh he's like [ __ ] old
batman it's amazing
um all right somebody asked here uh uh
um where was it it was pretty oh uh gay
lord of the rings
great name by the way uh holland was
great
in the impossible before playing spidey
you've you've seen that picture right
yeah yeah that movie is painful to watch
man
like [ __ ] cause you're like who like
there's so many she's got a big gash in
her leg he's all [ __ ] up
every part of that movie i'm like this
is where i quit just lay
down in the water and go to sleep and
just tell my wife i love her the two of
these [ __ ] man they just kept going
oh it's an unbelievable movie
um all right what else did i watch uh
there's a new documentary on hbo
called the lady in the dale
about a a a woman who uh
was invented the three-wheeled car that
was a sensation for like a red-hot
minute in the 70s before it turned out
to be a scam
the story goes way deeper than that i
don't want to spoil anything but
it's three parts are already up and it's
uh they do it
in this animated style where they take
stills and animate the stills to tell
the story so it's not just a series of
talking heads
it's very well done it reminds me of
in terms of like how interesting and
curious
and well made of mcmillions remember the
[ __ ] uh
that the hbo duck uh really [ __ ]
worth watching uh so check that out and
what else did i [ __ ] watch
cherry i watched that i watched
and then one division i didn't watch
anything like monday to thursday because
i was fasting
and generally speaking like when i'm in
the fast i can't
if i sit in front of the tv that's when
i just want to start eating so i didn't
watch anything for four days so it was
just friday and saturday
we're really just all thursday night and
friday we're all friday
and then it was last frog no thursday i
guess is when i watch
cherry thursday night um so yes check
cherry i'm sorry i'm sitting here
rambling about when did i watch [ __ ]
chairs
man audiences like [ __ ] you move on we
don't give a [ __ ] when you're watching
some dude in oslo is like the sun is
coming up he's like
fine it's like it is six in the morning
who gives a [ __ ] when you watch jared
wrap it up [ __ ] you've got to ask my
question
i've got a few words to deal with like
that's norway whatever
um um okay
uh chris he chris hernan on on chat says
who is jimmy wu's missing person
you got a theory on that going back to
it i don't
i don't know somebody online i don't
know who it was maybe comicbook.com or
some site said uh that wonderman's gonna
be introduced i was like what
how why do you know that like why am i
such a specific guess
wonder man that's my money double down
[ __ ] daily double bed at all like all
right man if you want
i guess man um all right oh i got a
little info here from sid diego says kev
when you watch tv should try
apple slices that's what i've been doing
um
let me tell you sid i'd rather [ __ ]
eat my own dick than an apple
thank you for the tip and also to be
fair eating my own dick would be
pleasurable
not eating my own dick and consuming it
like [ __ ] cannibal style and [ __ ]
you know i'm talking about just eating
my own dick can you can you point to the
doll and say where the apple slice for
you
[ __ ] them apples that was that was uh
unpro that was an unproportional
response apple's got another thing
[ __ ] coming man
um um let's uh
we got jc we're done with the news we're
done with the news my friend what up for
mark he gave you the [ __ ] news kids
um there's somebody in oslo said we got
better internet than you
[ __ ] right there yeah
i mean you guys invented bluetooth i
think so i hope so it's not it's not
saying a lot for heaven's sakes
everyone's got better than it
you know who's got better internet than
me the 90s
well the 90s held on to those aol disks
so yeah i know
i guess i mean if you give me a second i
can load in my aol disk and perhaps get
some better internet than the [ __ ]
version i'm working right here
um all right jc we got questions people
in chat they got questions they want
things they want to know
yeah we do tonight's chat was
interesting because there's a good chunk
of people
who i think started watching like 20
minutes to half an hour late
so like about an hour into the show i
got a lot of like
a lot more of like uh just tell kevin to
plug his internet in it'll be fine
even though we had already spent 10
minutes explaining it
so that's been interesting tonight uh
but
wait before we go before you jump this
is something i wanted to talk about
before and somebody just threw it in
eric mai is the aerospace engineer reed
richards remember when monica's like uh
you know i know an aerospace engineer
would like to take a crack at this
that's what i'm i'm i'm with this cat
the moment that was referenced i was
like
nobody just says that nobody just says
something in the marvel thing yeah
and it just starts like texting and then
well something else happened yeah i i
think it could be reid richards man i
think i
you know i know it could be they're like
mutants mutants mutants and then in the
back door they're like
ff you know what i'm saying like it
feels like they're pushing us toward
mutants
but it feels like we're getting a little
backdoor ff which sounds way dirtier
than i meant it
it's greggy you just got cranked jeff's
kiss
a kiss straight from the lips of jeff
excuse me while i kiss this guy
guy named jeff all right jc what do they
want to know you picked three questions
we're gonna answer these questions three
yeah i
this is a fairly simple question but i
really liked
uh gaylord of the ring's name also
uh gaylord dropped a question what are
some classic movies that kevin and mark
love
uh he points out he loves uh french
connection blues brothers
what's some good uh like vintage watches
for people
uh if you haven't seen all the
president's men in a red hot minute
or you've never seen all the president's
men go watch all the president's men
and then watch captain america winter
soldier right after it
and then watch three days of the condor
they all feel like similar movies not
certainly one doesn't copy the other but
they all have the elements of
i don't know if i trust this government
like it's it's
tense spy thriller stuff um and all that
barefoot in the park yeah then watch
that
watch then watch ordinary people a lot
of reference not in it
but it's really sad and
if you ever wanted to see a mother be
cold toward her remaining child who
didn't drown
while her husband looks on and all
canadian and [ __ ]
ordinary people is the movie for you
done
it's been a while um let me see what
else
i would say network is an amazing watch
if you're into dialogue
patty chayefsky's script one of the best
screenplays of all time
um if you like uh dialogue you know
like if if dialogue movie dialogue is
your porn
uh a man for all seasons from 1969 the
fred
zinman film about sir thomas moore is an
amazing
chatty movie uh you know naturally jaws
can't be missed um mark
um let's see i'm trying to write [ __ ]
down before i forget it
um wages of fear
i think i've talked about before um this
great old
french movie and by old i mean 50s it's
not like some 1920s jimmy jam
but it's about um four guys uh
completely down on their luck
in some like tiny forgotten [ __ ] like
jungle town who uh get hired
to drive two semi-trucks filled with
nitroglycerin
across unstable land over to a mine
um and it's basically it's a movie about
desperation
this movie about what what you can get
people to do when they have nothing else
to lose
um and it's this amazing it's just it's
suspense it's pure suspense
um william freakin um remade it later as
sorcerer
and the mandalorian then remade it later
as like episode
six of season two when you know
they've got to get through the jungle on
this [ __ ] thing you know what's on
all these things there's some unstable
chemical and bad guys like it's
it's all that same thing if you've that
trope has had a beginning and that
beginning is wages of fear
um double indemnity
is pretty great um uh
fred mcmurray um old film noir um
and it's just filled with twists and
turns and it's [ __ ] awesome
um i would always recommend
watching 48 hours if you want to see
um if you want to see just the beginning
of a [ __ ] star
you know like that that was eddie
murphy's very first movie
and you'd never know it and it's it's
walter hill
and it's crazy [ __ ] fun um
and it's like brutal and uncomfortable
and like
crazy racist um but also like
it's a relic of its time but still
really really enjoyable
um there is a
60s alfred hitchcock movie called rope
which um is this [ __ ]
and rope is noteworthy for a number of
reasons um
the first of which is that it's it was
one of the first movies to ever be
tempted as one shot i mean you can see
where they hide the cuts
because you know the technology then was
not nearly sophisticated as is now
so if you liked you know 1916 and we're
like i wish they would do this again
rope is like the first time they really
pulled it off
and like wonderful performances great
dialogue
jimmy uh jimmy stewart
eventually joins the fun yeah it's a
really wonderful flick
and the whole time you know if you're
cognizant of the fact that like oh my
god they're not
cutting this is all one continuous take
and like mark says they hide the cuts
but like
it's it's a you know a feat of
filmmaking like you know like
launched a thousand [ __ ] film school
ships a bunch of people being like i
want to [ __ ] be that clever and stuff
it's what made him one of the greats
yeah like the the masturbatoriness of
the like the unbroken steadicam
shot i think sort of begins there um and
i
am not the biggest musicals fan in the
world like i i
unless you're literally on broadway when
people can break into song because
you're already giving it enough
disbelief anyway
so i was never that big a fan of movie
musicals but singing in the rain
is a phenomenal movie um for any number
of reasons not the least of which is
just watching gene kelly
um do his thing and there's a there's a
muscular-ness to the way that he moves
and dances
um there and debbie reynolds again they
would say you know yeah she's doing the
same thing he's doing backwards and high
heels and it's absolutely true
um and it's a hollywood movie and so
it's all about
sort of making movies and story and the
transition from
you know silent um
to talkies and what that must be like
for for actors who are amazing in one
and then for kind of falling away on the
other
but there's a reason why it's a classic
and you'll recognize a good half a dozen
scenes in it because you've seen them
before
in any number of clips or montages but
it's worth going back to the source
and watching i will never recommend a
ton of movie musicals to anybody because
that's not my jam as i said but singing
in the rain is phenomenal
um there's one other i wouldn't call it
a flat out musical but one other
musical that i guarantee you would
[ __ ] recommend bro and that is
streets of fire another time another
um place we are going nowhere slowly
gotta get away from the past there's
nothing wrong with going nowhere baby
but we should be going nowhere fast
it's so much better going nowhere fast
tonight is what it means to be young oh
[ __ ]
such poetry joe lamont says uh kevin
talk about lone star
what the john sales movie okay
i love that movie uh in fact it's so
weird you asked cause i almost watched
it like
last week with my wife again for the
first time in years but uh
is that the lone star you're talking
about um
i it's it's a fantastic flick wow it's
like a random poem
and [ __ ] like is excellent
storytelling uh
excellent filmmaking but it it uh tells
a
multi-generational story over the span
of like you know multiple decades
um really like one of john cell's
greatest films but
a true american original classic that
doesn't get enough attention
as it should um oh and then he says no
lone star 80s cartoon i can't talk about
that
i don't have anything to say about i
can't help you
my bad uh rich williams says talk about
nashville
come on man [ __ ] altman like all
altman movies are [ __ ] great
you want to see a great altman movie you
watch yourself some [ __ ] mash
you want to see another great altman
movie you watch yourself some [ __ ]
the player
you want to see another grit we can do
this all night
i will say i have a massive altman blind
spot
um which ones have been the player
i think the player and i think i saw
shortcuts shortcuts is good too but yeah
miller he's he's good he's got some
interesting flicks he did wonderful
things with sound like just in terms of
like
you've seen it in the player here's a
shot of like eight people and you're
here he mic'd
all of them so he could like zoom past
one and you can hear a piece of the
conversation and go into the other and
stuff
he uh he was an interesting cat also a
huge stoner from what i understand
i buy it big respect for him um all
right jc what next
i was going to just pop in and say i
watched uh it's more of a recent
kind of classic but i watched social
network this morning
which to watch it now
knowing what facebook has become is
really fascinating
um and then also one of my favorites
which is on uh
hbo max is american graffiti which is
like very
sweet and earnest which you don't get a
lot in a lot of movies now
the maestro before he became the maestro
[ __ ] indeed his clerks if you will
um george uh making a movie about
growing up
where he grew up and what it was like
then
and then took a quantum leap forward
with his next movie which was
about some place he'd never been in his
entire life that was multifaceted and
everyone really gave him [ __ ] for a long
time just because
you know [ __ ] trade federations and
[ __ ] like that
also uh young harrison ford young
ronnie howard yeah youngster williams
you don't get happy days and you don't
get laverne shirley without [ __ ]
american graffiti
it's a great movie excellent okay we
have
ariana tane72
um if you had kevin vision
or mark vision what era would you be in
and who would be your sitcom co-star
so you guys get the power to alter
reality
what do you what do you create where do
you go
i mean i already did it and my sitcom
co-star is j
muse and we've been living for like 27
years
i've created my own [ __ ] reality
everything i deal with is only kevin
vision
um i'm so myopic with my head up my own
ass
so i can't imagine pretending some world
where i'm like oh i would do this
you've seen what i've been watching
kevin vision for the better part of 27
years hopefully you enjoy the show
uh subscriptions are down you know from
the 90s but
no complaints we can still keep it going
show's still happening
mark uh you know i'm i'm
tempted to to go to the eras that i
grew up in you know like i'm tempted to
to do like fresh prince of bel-air
um which i've been watching a lot of i
went back to the source and started like
i'm now in season six
of fresh prince i'm almost done um i'm
tempted to to try and
refurbish the cosby show and not call it
the cosby show
and not have bill cosby in it but still
have everybody else because
it's still a great show but i think i
gotta go [ __ ] stanford and son i
think i was so
[ __ ] just obsessed with the idea of
living in a junkyard
that uh yeah that's me dancing to the
music i can't we're not playing it but i
can still
[Music]
um
that man taught me how to have a heart
attack incorrectly that's what i
that's why i didn't think i was having a
heart attack three years ago
because i'm like i'm not clutching my
chest and going elizabeth
clearly nothing's wrong
red fox [ __ ] almost killed me that's
what that story comes down to
never believe a comedian kids they're
not being
serious they're liars
[Laughter]
funny funny liars that's all this
uh so yeah i go sanford and son and
dwayne when was the last
the last part of that jc i need a
sidekick yeah who's your co-star yeah
who's your coaster
your vision if you're the scarlet witch
if you're wanda
okay i'm gonna pick it from the marvel
universe simply because like that makes
it
a little bit more on message and not
just like my friend gary
who i knew was in seventh grade i mean
well i did my friend jay
true but he's in your universe already
here's a good thing you're a [ __ ]
wework
because if your wife hears you're gonna
pick some fictional character instead of
her as your [ __ ] co-star
like yeah no babe it's tom sawyer it's
my co-star on
i got enough of you all day i gotta go
to my fantasy with somebody this is just
make believe
yeah all right who's your co-star um my
co-star i feel like
um
michael pena from ant-man
i think he's perfect sitcom coaster
material
may i just interrupt you to say a jeff's
kiss my friend
what a fantastic choice jeff just
shifted jeff
yeah um
that was fun jc i believe that takes us
to our third
yeah i just want to call out uh rufus
leaking who said mark's co-star should
be victor garbo
victor garber oh god damn it that would
hurt so much
although it would be cool because then i
could ask mark like point blank like
what's he like
i built a fine ship for your rose i'm
sorry it's really funny if like one
night one week i'm off doing a movie and
mark's like
my co-host this week is victor gardner
yes for this week's black man beyond i
got the whitest person i could find
victor garber titanic the guy from
godspell he was so white he wore
white makeup on his face
um all right who's our third question of
the evening jason uh
anthony s asks uh in ready player one
they virtually play the lead of a movie
through the eyes of the star
so in the movie they did the shining
and uh in the book they played matthew
broderick
in war games which movie character would
either of
each of you play and which would you
dread to play
so it would have to be a movie you you
have to recite the lines of dialogue
acting against the people in the mood so
it'd have to be a movie you know
really well which one would you want i
don't want to pick one that puts me in
danger like i don't want to say like
[ __ ] return to the jedis i get killed
um i do know all the words to strange
brew
and i do know all the words to raising
arizona
both fun fun and you know there's a bit
of hijinks and some jeopardy but not
much
ask the question again
you can virtually you will virtually
play the lead of the movie through the
eyes of the star of
all the movies which movie character do
you play
bad news bears amanda wurlitzer
i mean we can be girls right jeff's
kissing [ __ ] deep
um in a world where it's ready player
one i could choose to be a girl
character can i well then i [ __ ]
choose to live my life through amanda
werlitzer
she was the greatest [ __ ] pitcher of
the north valley league ever saw for
heaven's sakes man
and she made a lot of money selling
those maps to stars homes which means
she knew where famous people lived
i like famous people so [ __ ] amanda
wurlitzer that's who i'm choosing to be
nice if not her tanner boyle
fair enough who would you like not to be
what would be the worst version of that
hitler and triumph of the will
i mean although he wins in that movie at
any rate
for a minute but ultimately no
plus winning at what cost mark what a
hard one
um bad character uh what uh what about
you
i think the one i would like to play
slash live
slash being would be uh
alex rogan and the last star fighter
i love you alex rogan i would like to
defend the frontier against zuer
and the codename and armada oh [ __ ] a
good choice
yes that sounds like fun you get the
girl you get to do some awesome cool
space flight [ __ ] you got a lizard buddy
riding a shotgun
no that sounds bad um as for the
character that i would least want to
play in a movie
um radio raheem and do the right thing
having seen do the right thing kids is
one of my five
top five favorite films of all time
having seen do the right thing
any number of times i co-sign with mark
on this one
you do not want to be your raheem you do
not
you get a couple cool moments which is
you get totally
the love hate love love love is knocking
out hate he's beating him down
love wins and you get the cool radio
battle
with the with the other guys on the
stoop and you get to say one of the
greatest lines in movie history
d [ __ ] d
[Laughter]
uh yeah almost anybody else in that
movie you have some fun
with pushing for mozzarella on this [ __ ]
sal
yeah you could be bugging out and [ __ ]
yo sal we gonna boycott your fat pastas
your boy cost me your good boy
there's your boycott
oh [ __ ] are you [ __ ] up your jordans
think shits is broke
and they've referenced black panther in
that movie at one point like black
panther eat pizza because they're
holding a black panther comic book
like three pizza
excellent pick i would say inigo montoya
and the princess bride
that's who you want to be or that's who
i would want to be
because he gets to say hello my name is
inigo montoya
you killed my father prepare to die and
he never gets killed
like all that time makes it till he gets
to kill his father's killer
good choice and then he gets to become
the dread pirate roberts
which you learn isn't actually that bad
of a guy no
he's and he's kind of made for the role
and [ __ ] all right so who don't you want
to be
uh anybody in a non-english film
i do not do well with foreign language
so like you put me in a
gadard movie i'd be screwed
how how uh how did you get to
like all day long i couldn't speak it
though i'd be speaking english and
they'd be like
uh we got a [ __ ] in oslo it's
six in the morning and you just broke
their hearts
they're like bye now to us we speak a
language too
i mean a thor movie maybe that's kind of
norwegian [ __ ] yeah there's there's some
subtitles there
what if they put subtitles under you in
real life so you could see and you could
reach
so if somebody said something you just
look down at their at their
dicks dick level whatever they said is
written across them
people like there's that crazy american
dick looker he's always staring at his
dicks
why is he i think he's reading our
[ __ ] subtitles
um moat's artistic number one
said did agnes kill the dog anyone have
thoughts on that
oh um yes
there it is ladies and gentlemen that'll
be the top of the news tomorrow on
comicbook.com very much
barbara thinks that i can just kill the
dog we didn't see him flip the coin
alan padini says what the hell kevin not
batman
[ __ ] no i don't want to live my life
through batman's eyes he saw his parents
get killed
that's why he does the things he does
that guy's head
who wants to be up there [ __ ] no and
think about all the horrible things he's
seen like we only see
the very colorful crimes and [ __ ]
sometimes the joker just disembowels a
[ __ ] do you ever see some [ __ ] cut
open and [ __ ]
got another [ __ ] stuck inside it ew i
don't want to see that that man sees
that kind of [ __ ] all the time
so [ __ ] that no bad none of batman's
life seems very fun
not at all he ain't have time he ain't
spider-man
you ask me if i want to see life through
spider-man's eyes i say
okay maybe i still stick with [ __ ]
bad news bears and amanda woolwiczer you
asked me if i want to see the life
through [ __ ] bruce wayne's eyes oh
hell no
sad and dark we know it from the song
darkness
no parents having money
um is that it is that all the questions
we got that's what we got
we thank you ladies and gentlemen for
giving us those
fun questions some [ __ ] to talk about
don't forget
you are as big a part of the show as me
or him
except you don't get any of the
advertising money from nativedo.com
n-a-t-i-v-e d-o dot com
ladies and gentlemen slash fat man to
get 20
off stop [ __ ] stinking
there's no good reason in 2021 for you
to be stinking the way you do
nativedo.com they were the sponsors
tonight
of this year program that you've been
enjoying mark you got something to plug
where can i get that shirt
um the shirt i'm wearing i don't
remember i don't know you make
that's a great shirt with a good shirt i
like that dude shirt
no you can get a a be humble but let
[ __ ] know t-shirt from
embattledclothing.com if you use the
code mark 15 say 15
off your first order um there are also
no other things that that website
besides my shirts um and it's pretty
sweet
so and hey you know what it's black
history month and if you want to support
a black owned business
that is one of them so by all means go
ahead show some love
[ __ ] hey man um and me
uh if you wanna you know [ __ ] help
out
a white owned business
you let me know where to go with that
one listen you've got 11 more months
wait until march and then join that
kevin smith club but not this month
um thank you all for hanging out with us
uh ladies and gentlemen this is always a
blast and stuff like that uh come back
we're gonna do it saturday
we'll do it saturday i think we might do
it in person
again right we may be at the scum and
villainy cantina i mean we'll still be
on
your computers but we're going to be
together indeed
same room with the spit guard in front
of us yeah no jeff's kisses between us
none whatsoever
um there it is ladies and gentlemen uh
we thank you for tuning in we thank jc
for making this all happen uh but there
ain't no show without the guy
over there over there over there
i never know how to do it there it is
give it up for mr mark bernardin
thank you boys and girls so much fun and
that ladies and gentlemen is fat man
beyond
for this week we we went [ __ ] beyond
it's oslo and back yeah again all the
way wherever that is we went there
uh for fat man beyond i am kevin smith
and i'm mark bernard
tune in next time next week saturday uh
same
fat time probably not the same exact fat
time probably earlier
same fat channel smodcast.com
or youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
live long impressed
you